Okay, Spencer, what are some tells that a BO is legitimately hungry to grow beyond just yes,
the direct question? Well, obvious one is that they're paying for ads, right? And here's how
I look at it. If you're paying for leads or you're paying for ads and you tell me you're
not hungry to grow, you're a dumbass. That means you're allergic to money, right? So number one is,
I think the biggest telltale sign is they're paying for ads. Now, does it get a little bit trickier
if they're on Home Advisor and you're like, oh, well, are they active on Home Advisor? Did they
have Home Advisor in the past? Now it's shut off. There's a difference between being on Home
Advisor, being on Andy's List and actually actively paying, right? But if they're paying
for Google Ads, it's a pretty good sign. But that's a good question, Spencer. I think, yeah,
Spencer asked that. For me, it's a feeling. For me, it's a soft skill. For me, I got to hear
their tone of their voice. I got to do that cold call and I can tell. And here's the advice I want
to give you is when you are in doubt, when you are in doubt if that business owner is actually
legitimately hungry to grow, heat check them, pull back right there on the spot, okay? Here's
the example. All right, get to the end of the call. Hey, Mr. Business Owner, you got done. You got
the phone number. I'm going to send you a couple of leads. Hey, let me just ask you this really
quick. And I hate to be like, you know, repeating myself, but like, are you hungry to grow? Because
look, I want to work with you. I'm willing to give you a couple of leads at no charge. But if
I'm going to just, if I'm going to call you with a lead that's live and you're not going to answer
the phone, just tell me right now so that I don't waste my time, okay? Because I'm only going to
work with one company. Are you actually hungry to grow? You just tell me what I want to hear.
I know when I say that out loud, that's like, oh shit, that's pretty bold.
Yeah, it is. But guess what? You right there by doing that pullback, you are going to give them
the chance that if they actually are not interested, they actually are not hungry,
they can just run along. They can let you know right there on the spot. Yeah, actually Spencer,
it's funny you asked that. I don't know, man. I don't know if we're like, we're actually that
hungry and blah, blah, blah. Okay, cool. Thanks for telling me. Thanks for telling me. Now,
is it just because you don't understand what I'm doing here or are you like, and maybe like,
don't be afraid to check people, man. A lot of times we get that, yes, yeah, it sounds good,
but we're like deep down, we know they're actually not interested. They're just telling us what we
want to hear, but we're so damn afraid to ask the hard questions because of what we might hear.
Be okay to ask that question, even if it means you might get the answer you don't want to hear,
because I'd rather do that than waste the next three days and three leads on somebody
who's ghosting me. Okay, that's the best thing. And all the other things, telltale signs,
when in doubt, do a pullback at the end of that first call. And if at the end of the first call,
it seems good. And then by the next call, they're dicking around with you, ghosting you,
do the pullback, leave them a message, call them, ask them, hey, man, I know we talked yesterday,
I gave you that lead, but I'm not getting the greatest vibes. Like, are you hungry to grow?
If not, I'll find somebody else and I'm not trying to be a dick. Do a pullback. Okay.